Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor Greene, a radical
Republican congresswoman who has been kicked off
of all of her committees and fined for refusing
to wear masks on the floor of the House to to high
heaven. She's been fined a high heaven at this
point. She is now lying that Joe Biden is paying
Tik Tok influencers now, as is almost always the
case. Sometimes they make up nonsense whole cloth
like. When she talked about Jewish space lasers
or lasers, as Lindsey Graham called them, that was
completely made up. But sometimes there's like a
kernel of something, and it is true that the Biden
administration met with Tik Tok influencers.
There was rampant, rampant Russian propaganda
on Tik Tok, and Tik Tok is a growing platform we
now are on. We're taking TikTok seriously because
we're having such explosive growth there nearly
100000 followers already. I think TikTok has grown
faster than any platform we've ever been on for
us, TikTok. It's growing. And so the Biden White
House met with a bunch of TikTok influencers.
They didn't pay them. They didn't pay them.
And Marjorie Taylor Greene says that not only were
they paid, they were paid off and paid off has an
additional pejorative connotation that it's, you
know, people are being given money to say specific
things they don't believe. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: And what is the White House doing
as the world slides dangerously close to
devastating World War? Paying off Tik Tok
influencers to lie for them more concerned with
favorable headlines from The Washington Post
and The New York Times than avoiding World
War, more concerned with social media likes
than protecting American jobs and families.
Speaker 1: So, of course, none of that is true.
And there are numerous reports about this.
Fortune magazine Biden is using TikTok
to fight back against Russia's reported
use of influencers to spread propaganda.
The White House countered holding, by the way,
it wasn't even like they flew people to D.C.
They did a Zoom briefing about Ukraine for
30 Tik Tok stars like that. That's the whole
story. That's the whole story. And it says
that National Security Council staffers in Jen
Psaki gave updates. And I mean, it's almost
like a just kind of like a non-story.
Um, and there has been significant use
of Tik Tok by apparent Russian propaganda
nodes. I guess we would call them to spread
to sow doubt about the innocence of Ukraine
in the context of the invasion, etc. And as is
often the case with a lot of these right wingers,
if they spent 10 percent of the time that they
spent lying about what Democrats are doing,
10 percent of that time working to actually fix
a problem, the country would be dramatically
better off. And this is one of the great
frustrations, which is we see the clip. It's
23 seconds of Marjorie Taylor Greene lying
about Biden paying off Tik Tok influencers,
and we debunk it pretty quickly. It's just it's
not true. It was a Zoom meeting. No one was paid.
That's all. It was great. We've established that,
but we are constantly kind of playing catch up in
the sense that there are real problems to solve
here, even when it comes to Russia and Ukraine.
What is going to be the long term economic
impact? What should be the U.S. perspective as
we become accustomed to the invasion? As you can
already see, there's less coverage of it even now,
the invasion still going on. But once a story gets
stretched out, you start to see less coverage or
different types of coverage. And so what should
be the continued attitude and media coverage
and sanction framework and all these different
things? And these are real things to figure out.
What about Ukrainian refugees? What about arming
Ukraine? But stopping short of the line that Biden
drew, which is troops on the ground? These are
all serious, important things. And Marjorie Taylor
Greene is out there saying Biden's paying tic
talkers and it's just a flat out and complete lie,
and I hate to use that tired phrase. This is
why we can't have nice things. But, you know, in
a literal sense, the fact that these are
conversations that have to be pushed back against
or these are these are lies that have to be pushed
back against. There's only 24 hours in a day and
people got to sleep right. And so by having to
say none of this stuff is happening in order to
protect the reputation of the people that are
actually working hard to try to solve problems,
we lose time and resources and just had space to
actually deal with those problems. And it's a very
sad thing. Let me know your thoughts. You can find
me on Twitter at David Pakman. Also, make sure
that you are following us on TikTok, where you can
find us at David Pakman show we are doing separate
tick tok only updates on the Russian invasion of
Ukraine, which you can follow there. We'll take a
quick break and be back with a very packed Friday
show for you today. The David Pakman Show does
depend on the support of listeners and viewers
like you through what we call the membership
program, we do an extra show every day for our
members and provide all sorts of other great perks
and benefits. You can sign up at join Packman
dot com. You can also use the coupon code wwr
22. If you so please, let's hear from some folks
from the audience. We had some beautiful calls
last week. We take calls via Discord, which you
can find at David Pakman dot com slash discord.